good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy tuesday hope
everyone had a great monday we are now
over the monday blues and it's a
beautiful tuesday another unseasonably
so warm uncomfortably warm day here in
new york and it's gotta stop
even in this just light sweater no
jacket i'm sweating
it is really so warm i should have worn
a t-shirt but that just
feels wrong no i'm dressing for the day
it's
november 10th i'm not dressing for the
weather i'm dressing
i'm dressing how people dress in
november i know well i switched it up to
flats instead of boots to like take off
a little bit of
show a little skin for you guys i mean
i'm [ __ ] sweating in my big ass
turtleneck for me
so it's like so cheap and itchy like i'm
literally about to crawl out of my skin
but i'm fine i'm fine
i think it's going to rain this week
which now that i'm a dog mom like i'm
really looking forward to the rain
because it washes away all the duty in
the streets
oh my god you are so wrong no no i mean
i know that like
it'll be annoying to take him out i'll
have to like go to scaffolded areas or
he'll go in the
on the wee wee man in my house but
there's like the streets need to be
cleaned
and the rain will wash it all away first
of all that's like not how it works i
feel like the rain makes everything
dirtier because then like
the trash is just like wet trash sitting
on the street
and then when you have when you have a
dog and it rains in the city first of
all the dogs
never go to the bathroom outside they
like can't figure it out they like lick
the rain
and then they get every time you go out
for just like an average pee should take
five seconds
takes 30 minutes and they come back
soaking wet it's the most annoying thing
me and margaret were just having this
conversation when it rains it's so
annoying to have a dog
yeah no i i understand that part but i'm
just i think it will clean the parts of
the street
that bother me i actually don't have a
lot of like trash on my block
but like there's other dogs pee and
stuff like that
so just a clean slate tabula rasa
um we have a great show for you guys
today i watched so much tv last night
like it was what did you watch there was
nothing on
okay so i watched the undoing okay which
is only three episodes in on hbo max
excellent you will love it nicole kidman
is a redhead and it's just
not what you expect i want to tell you
what it's about because i didn't know
what it was about and it was just
shocking but should i wait till there's
more episodes no because
like the whole world is watching it's
like you want to watch it with the world
really i did that with mick millions and
like
i was annoyed that i had to then wait oh
i did not know that the world was
watching mcmillions
i don't i don't know i think more of the
world is watching the end of the limited
series
i don't know i just know it's an hbo
show it's giving me major big little
lies vibes and over the weekend the
people that i was with like everyone was
talking about it's only three episodes
in and it's
so good oh that's tough i just love like
to watch my mini series all together
just have a little snack like chernobyl
if i had watched that like week to week
it wouldn't have had the same effect on
me i'm usually not a proponent of week
to week watching i think i can't believe
there was once a time
in our society where we watched
everything week to week it's it's brutal
like it's truly savagery
but um i actually really like this show
and i don't mind waiting week to week
it's like
i haven't watched week-to-week something
since game of thrones and you know
sometimes it's nice to change things up
well last night i watched the week to
week version of filthy rich because like
i'm sure the last few episodes are still
playing out even though it was cancelled
if you don't follow us on instagram but
you listen to the show you know that
yesterday we predicted because of our
love for it immense love
that it would be cancelled and sure
enough it is cancelled um
i don't i know you don't feel as
strongly about this as i do but i feel
like it's not too late like and you know
why i have this
feeling because of a place to call home
it was like supposed to end
like at the end of season two but then
there was a season three because there
was so much fan love for it
and i just feel like with the power of
the toasters it's not inconceivable that
we could all
like catch up watch the next two
episodes and show them like
there's a real audience for this show
yeah
i mean i i love the hope i really do
my only concern is that i don't like i
wasn't necessarily surprised when it got
canceled because
i had not heard about it from anyone or
anything like i just saw a commercial
for it and it's stuck in my mind it's
something i might want to watch
i don't know besides us like if there is
literally
any other person who watches it like
when gcb got cancelled like i knew tons
of people watching it like
nashville i'm like i see it everywhere
like everyone's talking about it it made
no sense
this actually like makes a decent amount
of sense like i don't know anyone
watching no to me this falls in the same
category as gcb
and then nashville was different but
nashville found a home at cmt like maybe
it needs to find another home
i just feel like i i agree with what
you're saying but i feel like everyone's
always like use your platform use your
platform like i want to use my platform
to save
filthy rich i think when people say use
your platform they're not talking about
that but like i'm going to use it thanks
for telling me to use it
okay also another thing that i watched
was jeopardy the first episode without
alex trebek
the uh producer very handsome young
thing
started out the show it's all
pre-recorded but he recorded like a
little thing of himself like just saying
how
you know the whole community and all the
producers the show runners everything
um they're devastated and alex like
loved the show so much and insisted on
recording
um all the episodes up until two weeks
ago and he got like a little choked up
it was very sweet and then at the end of
the episode it was dedicated in memory
to um alex trebek so it was a little
i feel weird watching things like
posthumously like it gives me like a
little like ghosty vibe
but it was very sweet and it was nice to
see him and i really felt like alex
trebek was watching down on me because
there in the first round was a category
on podcasts
what were the questions there was one
about bill nye's podcast
one about um it was really random like
not even joe rogan like it was
bill nye has a podcast yeah they're like
this science guy uses his podcast
today's science or whatever it's called
um it was super random i'm just like you
know
such a narcissist like i'm like there's
going to be one about the toast like and
i would have
like actually died but like i need to
relax and take several seats because
that's like not
was there any like proper like they
didn't talk about joe rogan
that's a miss was there were there any
rightful questions like about podcasts
that actually are popping
um not that i remember i knew most of
them but it was like
really random oh the conan o'brien
what's this late night host and i knew
it was conan
immediately um i don't remember the
other ones but they weren't memorable
like
yeah it was just not it but it was it
was i felt it was alex trebek connecting
with me
oh for sure that's beautiful and then
the other thing i watched was dancing
with the stars
because how many people are left a
million i couldn't believe how many
people were left because like it's
feeling from like the social media
viewership
it's feeling like there's three people
left i think maybe now there's five
okay neve caitlyn bristow
justina machado nelly
and guy skye did i say kaitlyn yeah okay
so five and then um aj mclean went home
last night okay
so i just feel like we've been talking
about it a lot and i really haven't
watched that much since the beginning of
the season so i wanted to like
you know see what was going on check in
and it's just honestly like it's so
insufferable like
there is absolutely no world where
caitlyn is not the best answer on the
show like she's just
immaculate and the scoring makes no
sense i thought she got three tens
no for for sure i'm saying for her but
see it reminds me remember when you said
when you guys
judge the redheads book you judge them
within themselves
not bit compared to other books yep so
it's like nelly
who is so sweet and such a pee job but
just like doesn't have the chops to
dance
he got an eight he ever jonate and like
caitlyn got a 10 and like in no world
were those two dances even remotely
comparable but it's like they're judging
nelly against himself because he's
getting better he got an
eight for him yeah and so it just like
the the scoring makes no sense
and i actually think derek huff is a
very good judge and he's only there
because len
because of kovid lives in london can't
travel i actually think like
he's worth he needs to stay because
the judging is just so archaic tara
banks is actually getting a lot better
um and i think that she could have a
real future as
the dancing with the stars permanent
co-host so
i'm glad for her for that i think it's
all good and well
and other than that the show was just
like a little too much for me like it's
so
um so many commercials and so many like
pre-packaged uh
packages all right we're gonna take a
pause there's construction going
on one second
okay we need to find out what time their
lunch break is
yeah and then record them and then
record at that time because that is just
not going to work and it sounds like you
know they've got a big project going on
and of course special projects it's
going to be ongoing
um so that's just not going to work like
construction in my ear
and those are the four things three
things that i watched last night did you
watch anything besides filthy ridge
uh no i was very busy with little bruno
last night i did a peloton ride which
she would have thought nothing to report
home
but i hit a per my personal i beat my
personal record
which i haven't done since august like
when i was like stronger
and it just made me feel really good
because i was like feeling really weak
for a while and then i don't know what
happened last time i used one of my
daily mixes on spotify
the songs were popping getaway car fly
with me and i was just transported and i
hit
a pr 246 output and 30 minute ride if
you're a pellet toaster you know what
that means to me
yeah i definitely don't work out a lot
but i do know that like a playlist
can change the world when when it comes
to working out you know one time i've
only taken a handful of soul cycle
classes
and one time i took this random class
where she played honey i'm good by andy
grammer and like
i wouldn't consider that like a workout
song but something with like how the
rhythm when you tap your pedals and
it really just like sent me into another
universe yeah so
i'm feeling good about that we have
actually some peloton news today
so palette toasters perk up it's some
good news and other than that yeah it
was just you know a run-of-the-mill day
got a lot of stuff
done i cultivated a vibe in the living
room again and i have to say ever since
i've stopped spending you know
23 out of 24 hours a day in my bed i'm
sleeping
much better because there's something
about like getting into bed
at 11 o'clock as opposed to like getting
back into bed at 11 o'clock you know
when you've been
hanging out there all day well actually
thanks to bruno i'm spending a lot of
time in my living room and i jump
and i don't hit the bed until it's time
time for bed which is weird and a new
sensation no and i kind of like it
yeah it's quite enjoyable yeah my couch
is a nice place to be yeah at first
it didn't feel warm to me because i've
literally lived in my apartment for two
years and not spent more than 10 minutes
out of time in my living room
but now that i'm like cultivating vibes
spending more time you know getting to
know the place
it's really it's a it's becoming a place
i could see myself in you know yeah
also something that i did that happened
yesterday that changed my day and now i
remember what i was doing all day i was
just enjoying the love of bruno because
he had his first grooming session
with um theo's groomer styled by ali
and he's a star she's amazing he
literally was just like
a ball of delicious sweetness
and i was just enjoying how good he
smelled and how
clean he was yes i literally there's
nothing better than the day after ally
comes and theo is just like walking
around
looking like a prince and smelling like
an absolute sometimes he smells like
i don't know like a movie star like so
rich and delicious like a movie star he
was wearing proverbs 31
yeah literally he was submitted by kim
catrell totally so that was a really
nice part of my day and
also i wanted to say yes we had a really
busy day because we were recording some
stuff after the show
and we recorded an interview with lauren
elizabeth because her new clothing line
lauren elizabeth collection drops today
so if you're listening to the podcast
the interview
will be at the end of this episode it's
so fun she's a podcasting queen
if you haven't listened to mood you're
missing out if you're watching this on
youtube
the interview is only available as
podcast so head over there because she
also gives out a special code for her
laura elizabeth collection drop which
she dropped the cutest it's today i
honestly i don't know maybe everything
is sold out but
um she dropped the cutest collection of
loungewear like very
chic beautifully you could wear it out
the code will tell you we'll spoil it
for you just in case you want to head
over now the code is toasters 20.
elizabeth collection it's really really
cute so enjoy that interview
make sure to check out lauren's
collection and lauren's podcast on our
podcast network toast news network
mood with lauren elizabeth dropping
episodes every wednesday it's a mood
with lauren elizabeth um should we dive
in i know we actually have six stories
today so like oh no
i i i whittled it down to five i made
this i knew the harsh cuts that needed
to be made in order to give
you the fast five stories that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast
and today i'm honored and proud to say
that the episode is brought to you
by palmer's new hemp oil coming relief
body lotion and body oil
the number one cocoa butter brand
introduces new hemp oil collection
palmer's new hemp oil calming relief
body lotion and body oil
calms soothes and hydrates even your
driest skin with a special blend of 100
natural hemp seed oil and skin
nourishing cocoa butter
for highly effective skin healing i've
been using palmer's cocoa butter like
forever on my lips and stretch marks and
it's just like such a fabulous brand
it's a type of brand where it's like you
release something i trust you yeah
it's a trustworthy brand 100 it's a
family brand i just i feel like really
safe in the arms of palmer
um it's ideal for sensitive and eczema
prone skin it provides dry skin relief
with its powerful moisturizers
hemp oil body oil soothes irritation
boosts hydration and improves skin's
texture and radiance
while the hemp oil body lotion
clinically is proven to air it
to improve irritation dryness and
itching
if you double up and layer the lotion on
top of the oil you will achieve
maximum hydration palmer's hemp oil is
skin care collection is dermatologist
tested hypoallergenic and safe for
sensitive skin
you can find these products in store and
online at walmart target walgreens or
amazon
the price is less than ten dollars each
so you gotta choose palmer's
choose what's real love it okay
let's start with like the big news of
the day tea is being spilled by larsa
pippen
she's breaking her silence on her
falling out with kim kardashian she's
blaming kanye west and travis scott
months after kim and larsa unfollowed
each other on instagram
fans of the kardashian jenner family are
finally getting answers about their
falling out
the 46 year old real housewives of miami
alum justice for real housewives of
miami
yes big time justice leah black woohoo
who has been friends with kim courtney
and chloe for years broke her silence on
hollywood raw podcast
on monday citing kanye as the reason for
their issues
do you smell that what desperation
that's what i [ __ ] speak with rd8
no it's like this fire we gotta go she
said if kanye feels like him and kim are
better without me then let them be
without me i'm okay with that i will
survive
i want everyone to be happy fans noticed
in july that kim wasn't keeping up with
larsette on social media anymore at the
time kim had said she wanted to reset
her account to just her family and her
childhood friends
that was something that i believed and i
really didn't think there was going to
be this sort of rift
with larsa but larsa says i didn't feel
any type of way i just felt like do
what's best for your family i love you
you and i are best friends
we've been through everything together i
would never do anything to jeopardize
our friendship we're like sisters we're
family but if you have to unfollow me to
make your home a better place
do it she said uh he talks so much about
me being this and that
i'm assuming kanye and this and that i
just feel like kanye was in a place
where he really didn't trust anyone with
kim
she went on to slam kanye several times
claiming that he's brainwashed his wife
and her sisters
when asked what she would say to the
rapper if she saw him lars has said i
don't know where's the love
the funny thing is i love him i love all
of them nothing has happened where it's
like i'll never talk to them again
i feel like people going through
different things and people handle
problems differently yeah i mean
there's so much to unpack here i feel
like the two major takeaways
for me from this interview were that she
kind of blames the rift on
kanye and she like happened to mention
that like she was actually seeing
tristan before chloe and then like
she flew tristan out to la and then like
10 days later he was dating chloe and
like she didn't even care because she
doesn't want to date someone who doesn't
want to date her
that's what she said i don't know if i
believe that but the the real shocking
thing to me
is now that she's gone on this podcast
and like kind of aired the dirty laundry
like there's no going back like you yeah
you fight with friends whatever maybe
you don't talk for a few months but
there's always the possibility of
you know coming back together but i
heard especially in the way that she
describes it like she keeps saying she
has so much love for them like maybe you
know there are different places in their
lives and the way that larsa is right
now is not someone that
kanye and kim like want to be around but
they're just like drifting apart
yeah but like people can also drift back
together
go on a podcast and air all of your
dirty lines so this is
your best friend's husband is
brainwashing her whole family so this
makes it official now it's like the
kardashians and larson will never be
friends again and that's what i find so
interesting because
someone like larsa whose entire like
livelihood is
really centered around being a
kardashian affiliate
i'm surprised that she would it's not
even like she's going on joe rogan like
she would go on a random podcast and
just like spill the beans
and i'm sure she's getting a lot of
press for it but that like fades super
quickly and i'm really surprised that
she would be so short-sighted
yeah and i'm not gonna lie from what i
saw of larsa on the show i did really
like her energy i thought she was really
funny and i think that
she kept like a lot of things light and
fun and just was always down
to have a good time and i i'm gonna miss
her
not that we saw so much of her just that
fight with that girl sarah where i just
like
it was so funny like the world is full
of larsas and sarah's
you know it's so so so so true and i
just like really
liked her but i also could see from what
she's describing
the only part of this that doesn't make
sense to me is that she would take it to
a podcast because
it's like if she still can speak that
say that she has so much love for them
and that nothing happened and
you know it's just different now i don't
know why you would like put the nail in
the coffin on that friendship
yeah no it's bizarre especially when the
friendship is so much more than a
friendship it's literally a livelihood
right and it's like a years-long
friendship
right that's what said it's like
honestly say what you want about the
kardashians but all the people that they
surround themselves with
are people who they have known for like
10 plus years like loyalty is such an
important thing to them and like
they don't even care like they don't
they don't want to be friends with you
like because you're cool or whatever
like it's because you're a loyal friend
and you've known them forever
so like when this is like a jordan woods
like when we when we break up with a
friend of a
very long time it's sad and it's really
shocking because the kardashians are
very loyal people like
everyone around them simon jonathan like
they've been around for years
yeah it's shocking i'm going to miss her
i didn't realize it i'm not we were
talking about it i just
i like aside from that one episode i
feel as though i don't know what she
brought to the table
and i don't care at all about her
being gone i don't know i think that i
think she was a good addition like
there's others i'd rather see go first
who i don't know but if i thought along
with enough about it i feel like i don't
know
what she contributed aside from that one
episode where i actually did like agree
with her 100 percent
i don't know she was never really ever
in the show otherwise
she i just feel like just from like
seeing her on instagram and like what
she's about i just feel like she's a
fun girl yeah but at the same time i
feel like she's in a
even though it appears like she's at the
same place in her life as like the other
girls like with her kids
i feel like they're actually very
different i feel like larissa like likes
to party and it's like single and like
proud and i don't think the other girls
are like that for sure but that's the
exact thing that i'm talking about where
it's like
this okay the single part no but like
likes to party like everyone needs that
party friend in their life but there
does come a time when
you graduate from the party friend and i
feel like that's where we're at and i
feel like for a while chloe was like
kind of the last one still in the party
phase and now it's like exclusively
kylie
yeah and kylie's not hanging out with
larson and also maybe it was really like
quarantine you know even if you were a
party girl before quarantine like
things change you know when party girls
are forced to stay home
check on your local party girl because
we are not doing
okay you guys like it's been a very hard
time for us
so you know if you're if your friend is
like that girl like check on her because
she's [ __ ] lonely it's isolating you
guys very depressing
i can't imagine having gone into
quarantine in like the peak of my party
girl days
because i like graduated from party girl
academy years ago
years before this happened and i was
really ready for
you know a lot of things i mean i wish i
had bruno sweets at the beginning but
you know
man plans god gets you a puppy eight
months later
but if you take anything away from this
episode it's check on your your local
party girl
yeah she's your local town drunk okay
because we are we're suffering yeah
she's suffering
big time okay next story is the story i
don't know if you've heard yet but i'm
really
really looking forward to getting your
thoughts because i'm pretty sure if i
know you well it's a person that you
don't like
oh okay and there's nothing better okay
then i love that the grinch musical is
coming to nbc what do you mean
if i sent you this story you did to post
i mean to talk oh i i
found it myself of course we need to
talk about this because i hate this
person
okay i'm just going to tell you the
deeds and then claudia's going to go off
love it okay the grinch musical is
coming to nbc
all is sounding really good until with
matthew morrison
the grinch is hitting the small screen
nbc is bringing the classic dr seuss
tail to life in a new musical
holiday special airing december 4th it
will be a two-hour production titled
dr seuss's the grinch musical from the
troubadour wembley park theater in
london starring glee alum matthew
morrison
as the titular character titular reminds
me of moira rose
morrison has also been in the good wife
and grey's anatomy and he starred as jm
barry in a 2015
broadway production of finding neverland
he also is mr
shu in glee which is really the only
thing that qualifies him for this role
no actually in terms of qualifications
i'm let me be totally fair and unbiased
grey's anatomy in terms of
qualifications
he's definitely um qualified 100 his
background
glee broadway like he's a triple threat
it's not about
it's not about talent because i do think
that he has it i'm saying they were they
were citing other things that he's been
in like grey's anatomy but that doesn't
tell you why he's great for this part
glee shows you why he's like
they called him the glee alum they did
yeah they did you ready sorry
so this concept is
sensational you know a two-hour grinch
nbc musical
love the songs the music and i don't and
i don't see the word live in here so i i
it'll be good so it'll be good
so that's great but i do think that
we are entering dangerous territory when
we start casting people like matthew
morrison
and here's why he played the somewhat
iconic role of will shuster
the substitute teacher and glee teacher
on
the hit show glee where he was just
consistently like very inappropriate
with the children
and it was all made to like seem okay
and now when we like go back and watch
some of the [ __ ] mr shu like did and
said it's like
so [ __ ] weird and i hated matthew
morrison like as the show was on
i just like he's something about like
his curly hair and his butt chin like
you want to know why
because he reminds you of justin
timberlake they're so similar it's a
similar vibe
that if you hate one you hate them all
that is true
that is very very true and i think it
was also like
in the show the kids were so supremely
talented like all of them were really
really stars
and yeah we were always listening to mr
shu singh and we're like [ __ ]
move the [ __ ] over like the kids are
better than you at least for me that was
the main problem and something about i
can't put my finger on why
matthew martin like bothers me so much
but it's not just me it's a whole
society of people
yes there's there there is a real group
of people
who really don't like matthew mark no
and we are we deserve to have our voices
be
heard and i feel like i want to give a
voice to those people because we are not
okay with this like
we are taking a perfectly good idea and
we're ruining it yeah
also a new fun fact about matthew
morrison is that he was engaged to
michelle and now this is the second time
that like rochelle has entered my mind
in the past five this morning because
she also showed a
home to larsa also another thing and
dancing with the stars dancing with the
stars so they were
out last week so um krishell wasn't on
this episode but gleb was because like
the pros like stick around like clap you
know for other people and it was weird
to see him i feel like he felt awkward
and like i felt awkward
feeling awkward feeling looking at him
feeling awkward you know
yeah um some more of the cast though
some good casting news dennis o'hare
will
co-star as old max booboo stewart um who
is from
twilight descendants and julian the
phantom she and twilight
um he was one of um
jacob's oh
yeah and then he's also one of the main
four in descendants
got it and he's the best and he will be
playing young max
and max is the dog there's a young max
and amelia minto who's in the wait
what's with this guy booboo constantly
playing dogs first he's a wolf
that was a dog i don't know amelia ninja
will try cindy lou who
oh she's a newcomer so maybe it'll be
her big break yeah no i mean i don't
know any of the people you just named
but i'm happy for them all and as long
as it's good like i will be watching
um i will be watching i will i mean i
don't know if i'll actually watch it but
like i'm gonna plan to watch it yeah of
course no but who knows where i'm gonna
be i might have laundry to do
the grinch is truly one of my favorite
christmas movies there's so many
elements to it
that um make it such a success i mean of
course jim carrey like
the best actor of all time then there's
jenny humphrey who plays the little girl
which is just iconic
singing where are you christmas written
by mariah carey
then added another layer molly shannon
is the mom and that scene where she's
decorating her christmas house like
trying to get it better than her
neighbors like is literally my favorite
scene of all time
and also the mayor is played by
someone else who his name i can't
remember but it's just an iconic cast of
people
it is it's an amazing movie and i really
hope that they do it justice and i hope
they never redo it like i like this
version and maybe this could be the
thing
that turns you on matthew morrison no i
don't think so i i
appreciate you you're too far gone i'm
too turned but i really do appreciate
the optimism and light you bring to this
show but
not today okay maybe another time no
today
i know that theo is upset that he was
passed on the role as max
yeah but you know what there's you'll
you can't have them all look at him he's
so down in the dumps like
down in the dumps but there's always
next time to you
don't worry don't worry your time will
come he's going to get the role of toto
for sure okay someone is going to be tt
some exciting
news for pella toasters beyonce has a
new collab
with peloton beyonce and peloton have
teamed up
on a multi-year deal that will bring a
series of themed workouts paying homage
to historically black colleges and
universities
and the timing couldn't be better
playing off of homecoming her iconic
coachella concert film
beyonce's helped create cycling running
strength boot camp yoga and meditation
classes
with peloton to commemorate the annual
fall homecoming season at hbcus
the singer was already the most
requested artist among the fitness
companies 3.6 million members
so the collab makes total sense where
can you request artists i have a lot of
requests
to make i've never seen a suggestion
you're gonna request matthew marson
i'm gonna request um taylor swift
honestly honestly for this partnership i
think is such a good idea and i always
feel like whenever it's announced like
who beyonce's partnering with
it just like makes so much sense i feel
like the the partnerships department at
beyonce hq like is just
geniuses like every time with the ivy
park and then it was that top shop and
then it's like a part of adidas like
it's just everything she does is like
really really smart really really smart
in addition
uh beyonce and peloton are gifting
two-year digital memberships to students
at 10 different hbcus
which provide access to the fitness
classes through the peloton app that can
be used with or without
equipment so i think this is such a
great partnership it's great for the
brands and it's also this is something
that really benefits the consumers
because beyonce themed rides are going
to be amazing
i used to do some beyonce themed rides
when i used to go to soulcycle and
there's just
so many good motivating songs and i'm
glad that her catalog is coming to
peloton i think
the entire experience will benefit from
it i agree um i actually saw a funny tic
tac of a girl who didn't want to pay
like 3 000
for a peloton so she brought her
bike into her house and like set it up
on this machine that makes it stationary
and then put
the peloton app on her tv and it
honestly worked beautifully yeah that
sounds but then she just has like a bike
in her living room yeah a real bike
that sounds like just kind of dirty a
good idea but it's a good idea yeah yeah
along with the big partnership coming
during homecoming season the timing is
also good for the company in the stock
market
because peloton was up with the queue
and now it's down with announcement of
vaccine but now this is good for news
for them again yeah i wonder if they
were really impacted business-wise by
the soul cycle back i actually know a
lot of people who have it
yeah and i feel like now anyone who's
seeking to get a bike is really on the
fence and i feel like if
if the soul cycle bike had existed when
i was
bike buying i would have gotten this
whole cycle bike 100 yeah i'm sure
because soul cycle has so many customers
and those customers bought pelotons
because soul cycle took
a year too long to come out with a bike
and it's it probably keeps them up at
night
not even a year too long like four
months too long the timing was just so
bad
yeah but i'm sure people are still
buying you know i'm sure it's successful
but it could have been huge aces yeah
yeah cases okay next story a follow-up
from yesterday
who will replace alex trebek as the
jeopardy host oh sorry
the other thing i wanted to say about
watching jeopardy that i totally forgot
to mention is that in the first round
one of the categories was hosted by ken
jennings
so every time somebody chose from that
category they had a video of ken
jennings reciting the clue
which just really made me think like he
definitely is a contender that's what
people are saying
apparently he has been like producing
some of the show and they've really been
like grooming him for the job
but other names that are being thrown
around are george stephanopoulos
i don't think that's going to work
because george stephanopoulos does
politics
and i think that jeopardy is like a
universal show
and they need someone who's like totally
neutral oh i think
at one point alex trebek he might have
been joking but he nominated fellow pop
culture icon betty white i think he was
joking but i would i would accept it
ken jennings who to me is looking like
the front runner yeah
alex faust who is the la king's hockey
announcer
yes i heard that like alex just really
respected him and like
thought he had a nice voice yeah i feel
like um that could work
like someone who just has like hosting
chops who we don't know that well who's
gonna make their
mark at jeopardy not someone who's made
their mark we know so much about them
and then they're gonna bring all that to
jeopardy i do think it could be someone
like that
also um cnn legal analyst laura coates
was a name floated
by trebek and i think those were the six
yeah those are the six in the mix
i mean they're all sound like perfectly
good options and i'm sure any of them
would be
like decent at the job but i do think
that it's so much more than like being
able to do the job it's just like what
it means and i really think ken jennings
is the guy and it would just be it would
be like a really really beautiful like
way to end the story if it went to ken
jennings i agree and it's a great
message it's like
not only if you're going to be the
smartest and the best like you will get
you will win the prizes and whatever but
like
you know you could it could aspire to be
even more and i feel like it also really
encourages like people makes being smart
cool
a hundred percent makes it being smart
can make you a celebrity
yeah and i feel like like famous for
your smarts yeah no i
completely agree and i just think for a
million reasons of all the people you
named ken jennings is like so clearly
the right person for it
um and all he needs is like a couple you
know classes on
enunciation hosting reading off a
teleprompter it's easy
and people have said i was concerned
yesterday but people have said that he
is warmth and he can bring the warmth
into the living room well so yesterday i
was saying this category
was all ken jennings reading the clue
and i feel like it was really like a
trial run for him
um and he looked mad cute i did have i
did have some problem with his
enunciation that was
the beauty of alex trebek i think it was
his canadian accent like he
just announced everything perfectly like
in terms of
pronouncing words that were like foreign
or hard to hard to say
that is a really um huge skill so
we'll see we will see you guys we'll see
we shall see
okay see we shall fifth and final story
some happy news the viral
dream skateboarder has gotten engaged
congrats are in order for the fleetwood
mac dream skateboarder nathan
apodaca he popped the question to his
girlfriend and she said yes
sources close to the couple tell tmz
that nathan proposed to his girlfriend
estella on saturday night in las vegas
dropping to one knee at the nobu hotel
inside
caesar's palace this is like the
sweetest story and
every time i hear an update on this guy
who if you don't know
he made a tick tock that went completely
viral of him like riding down we spoke
about it on the toast yeah riding down
um i think he lives in phoenix like this
beautiful highway the sun is setting
he's drinking some ocean spray
cranberry juice on his longboard and
it's just like people were really vibing
to it
and and listening to dreams by fleetwood
mac right and now they literally took
that um
tick tock and made a commercial for tick
tock with it um it just blew up a
million celebrities
replicated it he's getting brand deals
he has merch
he has like 10 million followers on tick
tock now he has a lifetime supply of
ocean spray and they gifted him a truck
so i just feel like i don't know i feel
like he's like a good guy like the first
like okay so he got famous and a month
later the first thing he did he's
obviously making a lot of money now like
it's by his
longtime girlfriend a ring like that's
literally so sweet so
so sweet i feel like it's been a while
since we've had one of these like viral
sensation moments where some ordinary
person just becomes a superstar
overnight
and it's always really exciting i can't
believe he hasn't been on ellen yet
she's like always monopolizing on like
viral sensations mostly kids but still
yeah that's a good point it really has i
can't remember the last one that we've
had
yeah i remember alex from target yeah
but even mason ramsay like that's
really how he started mason ramsay's the
last one the selfie kid from the super
bowl
okay that was so that that guy i mean it
was so manufactured
no i'm not saying he was a cute kid i'm
saying the whole um career created
around him was so manufactured it wasn't
like natural
this went naturally organically viral
like people just vibed with it literally
i didn't even look twice at that kid at
the selfie and suddenly he's like the
selfie kid i'm like what
yeah that was manufactured by like by
literally like a talent agency it was
fake
the backpack kid yes that feels like
another manufactured one to me
no he seems more real to me because i
actually had seen him do that weird
dance move
um like virally on on certain social
media platforms but
it wasn't as big as me i think jason
ramsey is probably the most recent one
who
really became famous yeah
from like just an ordinary moment in an
ordinary walmart in an ordinary town in
america but with an extraordinary kid
and an extraordinary talent um sounds
like the end of a hallmark movie oh also
one thing that i meant to send you as a
story today
hulu is now releasing their own
christmas movies and they are now
they're releasing the first one ever
with a lesbian main character
by kristen stewart oh my god that sounds
amazing oh and her the supportive like
you know gay best friend is dan levy oh
my god that sounds so good yeah
competition is great for the consumers
you guys
100 when they compete we win we
win so now more christmas movies more
christmas movies more diversity
the bachelorette is on tonight tasha's
first episode
um that'll be good yeah i was thinking
about it last night and of course i love
tatian i'm excited but
she's gonna be great at being the
bachelorette thus making the show like a
little boring like
something about claire like breaking all
the rules and like getting angry with
all of her decisions like makes it much
more interesting to watch
i completely agree like when we read
kevin we're just gonna be here like i
love tasha yeah who will she choose
yes she's such a great girl so many
connections yeah so like
i'm sure there'll be more to it that's
interesting but at the end of the day i
feel like she's just gonna be like a
really good bachelorette i feel like she
really
appreciates like the opportunity she's
been giving which makes it a little
boring
yeah no it's just run-of-the-mill
bachelor at the most dramatic season
but we'll still be here recapping it
because what else is there to do you
know
i'm looking forward to it and we have a
big week of tv wednesday we have
real houses of salt lake city which like
i literally cannot wait for
the watch party and i think it's pups
together that's also real housewives of
orange county
yes and then thursday is kardashian
southern charm oh and also tomorrow
night is the cma awards
oh would you be busy it's been a whole
year since we
hit that red carpet and honestly it hit
us right back yeah no we needed the year
to recover
yeah no honestly the cma awards like
doing the red card but i think we've
done it now three years in a row
are literally like the it's the best day
of my life
yeah we should watch the live stream on
wednesday like before the awards and
then watch the awards
okay like watch our stream except it'll
make me sad because i was so snatched
and
now i'm anti-snatched the uh
i don't know what i was gonna say i was
gonna say thank you guys but do you have
anything else you want to say before i
wrap up
no just want to thank theo like once
again for being like the
best addition to our show i 100 thought
he was going to throw up because he's
like been having belly problems i
remember he threw up on the show a few
months ago that was so sad
yeah but hope but i didn't want at least
like he waited till the end of the show
right so maybe if i wrap up he'll get up
and throw up yes and if you're listening
as a podcast we're wrapping up but then
you're going right into your interview
with lauren elizabeth and
it's premium and you're she's going to
let you know how to get some
bed vibes going bed productivity bed
vibes like making the bed the place to
be we are ending bed shaming culture it
was a really um
fabulous episode she's just so funny and
like easy to podcast with and she's like
just a toaster so it's fabulous to talk
to her
yeah um thank you guys so much for
listening to the morning toast
millennium morning show where we deliver
the fast five stories that you need to
know every monday through friday
on youtube so if you're watching us on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcasts can be found it's not
spotify itunes stitcher public radio i
have ready cast box all the places
so whoever you listen to podcast find us
morning chose to leave a five star
review about how beautiful stunning and
smart
we are we hope you have an amazing day
we'll see you tomorrow